az érdekelne hogy szerinted ez a pubg
milyen képességeket fejleszt a amit való
életben is használ tehát hogy beszéltünk
már arról hogy megtanulsz emberekkel
együtt közösen stratégiázni megtanulsz
magas stressz alatt fókuszáltan egy
stratégiát
végigvinni reflexek most ezek jutnak
eszembe még valami jut-e neked eszedbe
ami hát én amit a legfontosabbnak tartok
az a az a csapatmunka az a csapatmunka
az a csapatmunka én sokkal jobban tudnám
dolgozni egy olyan csapattal akikkel
játszok is tehát hogyha most a pincér
társaidat kiválaszthatnád a a pubg-sek
közül akkor szerinted jobb pincérek
lennétek közösen mint szerintem igen így
van még megosztanátok így a munkaután is
leültök akkor egyet játszani persze